Ray dalio the founder of Bridgewater
Associates who's worth 19 billion
dollars who has built one of the most
powerful companies in America book He's
written that every executive CEO must
read principles changed his position on
cash recently but I first want to read
to you what he said in 2020 about cash
on January 21st 2020 he said cash is
trash get out of cash there's still a
lot of money in cash however just
recently he changes position and said
the following he no longer thinks cash
is trash he thinks that the short-term
interest rate is now about right meaning
it's a good time to have cash so now if
you're listening to this saying wait a
minute how do you change your position
from cash being trash to cash not being
trash and buff it when he had 128
billion dollars in cash everybody was
saying well he's not doing the right
thing and just recently Q2 Buffett was
sitting on 105 billion dollars of cash
how can dalio say something like this if
you follow his content closely he says
the following in his book here's a tweet
from him in 2019 August 31st of 2019 he
says if you don't mind being wrong on
the way to being right you learn a lot
and increase your Effectiveness but if
you can't tolerate being wrong you won't
grow you make yourself and everyone
around you miserable here's one of the
principles recognize that mistakes are a
natural part of the evolutionary process
and here's a man who's worth 19 billion
dollars and says cash is no longer trash
right so for you if you listen to this
how do you process this I follow what
both of them says I listen very closely
to what Ray dalius is one of my favorite
interviews I've done on the past and I
follow very closely what Buffett says
because Buffett's the goat based on what
a lot of his peers say what he's done is
unbelievable the last 60 years he's
somebody everybody follows their
competitors his enemies his peers
everyone follows so how do you handle
this both billionaires Whose advice
should you take here's the reality of it
for me I consume a lot of content I
consume a lot of books I consume a lot
of different philosophies but that
doesn't mean everybody is a hundred
percent right or everybody is 100 wrong
Cash's trash is right when the stock
market's growing and exploding at 10 15
20 in a three year run rate if you stay
in cash you're going to miss out on a
lot of money but cash is also King when
the economy takes a hit and it keeps
going lower you wish you had some you
know dry powder right now to be able to
go out there and prepare in case of a
crisis happens to buy a lot of
opportunities so which one is right what
should you do for yourself with your
Investments this is how I process it
there are certain philosophies I
followed that I believe are evergreen
meaning
I prefer to stay Paranoid by always
having a little bit of cash because
opportunities could come up for me to
buy a lot of different things imagine if
your name is Warren Buffett say you have
105 billion dollars today
if you have 150 105 billion dollars in
cash and Berkshire Hathaway today what
would you be doing today dude you're
like going window shopping you're like
oh that's a nice pan that's a nice
wallet that's a nice purse
that's a nice jacket that's a nice suit
but you can't buy anything because you
don't have cash you know what Buffett is
doing oh that's a nice company that
should be a 28 billion dollar company
but it's worth 6 billion let's buy 12 of
it oh that's a nice company that should
be an 82 billion dollar company but it's
worth 13 billion by 25 of it oh I love
that company right there look at that
company it's sexy it's attractive the
market is looking at it and it's worse
than what it really needs to be let's
look at the numbers let's go back 22
percent of that company as well that's
what happens when you have 150 105
billion dollars of cash during times
like this and while everybody else said
Warren Buffett may be losing his mind
he's getting too old Warren Buffett
ended up being right in this situation
because he gets to buy so many different
things that's on sale today because he
has cash so whether it's a ray dalio
whether it's a Warren Buffett whether
it's anybody else giving their
philosophies whether it's me sharing
with you my content here on value it
doesn't matter what it is still go do
your own due diligence and come up with
certain specific philosophies but here's
the reality of it even your own
philosophies you come up with you could
still end up being wrong at certain
moment at a certain time because some
philosophies are going to get challenged
they may be good on a certain economy
they may be bad in another economy but
the part of doing anything big in your
life is you're going to be wrong many
times if you're going to be wrong being
worth 19 billion dollars I'm sure you
don't have a problem being wrong and if
you're going to be Warren Buffett being
wrong at certain times being worth 100
billion dollars I'm sure you also are
not gonna have a problem being wrong so
what's the whole moral of the story here
get comfortable being wrong because odds
are you're going to be many times having
said that if you got value from this
video give it a thumbs up subscribe to
the channel and if you've never watched
my interview with Ray dalio click here
to watch the interview with Ray dalio
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]